well we can bring in retired Air Vice
Marshal Sean Bell
um Sean we were hearing a bit from Alex
Rossi there about why the Russians uh
want it just give us the bigger picture
and it's sort of a staging post to back
mode
yeah I mean why solidar is the because
it's a relatively small village in the
middle of nowhere really if we look at
the map and it started off with a
special military operation and Putin was
trying to seize Crimea also land bridge
out back and to hold the donbass they've
seized both the former luhansk has been
taken half of Donetsk has been taken and
you can see the empty area here that's
what Russia's focused challenge was the
Russian army then stalled at back moot
the Wagner group led by prigorsny has
been the ones that the mercenary group
have been trying to attack they tried to
knock down the front door of buff boots
but end up with massive casualties doing
that and eventually military sense
prevailed and they've started trying to
encircle it because by encircling the
Ukrainian forces you force them to
decision to either withdraw or to fight
it out and that's why solidar has been
such a vicious fighting it's worth also
contextualizing as Alex pointed out that
the vaal groups led by pregozny an
actually convicted thief and he has his
own agenda with all of this he's got his
own agenda from a political perspective
also so from business perspective up
till now this is Sujin using pragos
suited Putin because Putin is you know
judges that Russian Society will be more
tolerant of losing convicts on the
battlefield than their new newly
mobilized men but he's now delivered the
first Battlefield success
for several months on the battlefield
and that will increase his power and
influence which will be a concern for
Putin from a military perspective the
worry was when this fell would that mean
the floodgates open and the encircling
happened the preventive view is that
will not happen the ukrainians have
exacted such a huge price from Russia
for just taking this small village that
they will need a breather now but it
does hint at where the focus will be in
the spring for the Russian offensive one
of those main costs of course the human
cost yeah both sides um talk a lot about
human costs they both over egg it it's
very difficult to work out exactly
what's happening to the Ukrainian forces
here
um it is worth saying that on the
offense you generally lose more people
than you do on defense on defense the
Russians are on the offense they're also
using untrained cons convicts that
therefore mean they're going to be at a
higher rate but just put some numbers
around this so Ukraine even though
they're claiming when we can't ratify
the figures they talk about 114 000
Russian soldiers have died in context
the British army is 80 000 so that's
fifty percent more more people than we
currently have in an army they're
claiming that they've destroyed over 3
000 Russian tanks we have 400 tanks in
the British army inventory these numbers
are huge now notwithstand the fact
Russia is even bigger so it's a
proportion of Russia's inventory it's
it's much smaller but it's actually
pretty clear that despite Russia having
a lot of Tanks many of them have never
seen the light stand are not usable so
it's it's pretty significant impact on
the Russian military machine at the
start of what's likely to be a long
winter which most analysts say favors
Ukraine how does Russia recover from
these losses to keep up assaults of that
magnitude short answer is not quickly
um the the you can organize your
Manpower pretty quickly because you can
mobilize that's what Russia did with 300
000 that solves the quantity so it
doesn't provide the quality because
they're untrained and they don't have
Battlefield experience on the equipment
side to replace tanks it's a lot more
difficult it's not just the the hardware
it's also the huge amount of Technology
packed into side and that's where
Western sanctions are really biting
Russia at the moment only overnight the
ministry of British and Ministry of
Defense advised that Russia is using
more convicts this time 250 to go and
work in their National tank Factory to
try to bolster the production line I
can't imagine how that will actually
improve the quality it may improve the
number of Tanks rolling out but not the
quality so the short answer is Russia
will regenerate but this process takes
years not weeks all right Sean as ever
thank you very much for clarification